[Musica]
[Applauso]
oggi oggi vi parlerò di alberi e di
foreste vi parlerò di alberi di foreste
per due motivi il primo è molto
personale sono la mia passione che ho
trasformato nel mio lavoro
il secondo invece interessa tutti ed è
il motivo che noi come umanità ci stiamo
progressivamente disconnettendo dagli
alberi ha delle idee le foreste nei
corsi nel corso dei millenni
lasciamo sempre meno spazio sul pianeta
questi sistemi che stiamo
progressivamente sostituendo con altre
cose i campi città riporti le strade
tutta una serie di sistemi che noi
pensiamo siano più utili o fondamentali
per la nostra civiltà ma ci siamo
realmente chiesti come sarebbe il mondo
senza alberi
lo sappiamo intendo come cambierebbe la
qualità della nostra vita senza le
foreste attorno a noi ma serie di
domande
ragioniamoci un po ma facciamo passo
indietro partiamo dall'inizio da quando
eravamo bambini e sognavamo
molti di voi sono sicuro hanno fatto di
costruirci una casetta lassù in cima
agli alberi posto strano per costruire
una casa però così affascinante ci dava
una visione completamente diversa dal
mondo lo guardavamo dall'alto e ci
sembrava in quella prospettiva che le
cose fossero fosse al posto giusto
io penso che il motivo per cui da
bambini nella nostra infanzia pensiamo
che gli alberi siano il luogo dove va
costruita la casa e perché in fondo gli
alberi sono stati la prima casa
dell'umanità noi siamo evoluti scendendo
poi da quegli alberi evitando inizio
assumendo per la posizione eretta
proprio l'antropocene a quel periodo
nella quale l'uomo sta cambiando il
mondo e l'ha fatto innanzitutto proprio
togliendo gli alberi nel paesaggio e
sostituendoli dapprima
con l'agricoltura con i campi poi
abbiamo scoperto il petrolio carbone
metano l'energia e con l'energia siamo
riusciti a costruire le città dove
stiamo portando la civiltà
nell'ultima fase della sua esistenza in
questo passaggio
chiaramente ci stiamo allontanando dagli
alberi e quindi se ripensiamo a quella
casetta che volevamo costruire ci
rendiamo conto che forse hai
raggiungibile e stiamo cercando di
trovare un surrogato quindi gli
appartamenti più ambiti di milano adesso
diventano una cosa così invece di avere
la casetta sull'albero stiamo portando
proprio gli alberi sulle nostre case
questo però un cambiamento nel paradigma
tra noi e gli alberi noi prima eravamo
ospiti della natura adesso la ospitiamo
in una forma addomesticata sulle nostre
case
e mentre facciamo questo siamo sempre di
più su questo pianeta
ieri eravamo sette miliardi e seicento
mila e più persone sono nati 200 mila
persone in più ieri 70 milioni
quest'anno una nuova italia e
contemporaneamente abbiamo sempre meno
foreste circa 50 per cento delle foreste
sono scomparsi negli ultimi 500 anni e
ogni anno sul pianeta
scompaiono scoprire una superficie di
foreste tropicali che è pari a 5 volte
la lombardia è allora nello studiare il
rapporto tra foreste uomini mi sono
chiesto perché non facciamo
semplicemente il rapporto matematico tra
la superficie delle foreste e il numero
di uomini in questo rapporto espresso in
quel grafico in quella linea come vedete
sta cambiando molto rapidamente nel 1990
quando quel grafico inizia io mi
laureavo in scienze forestali e di
uomini in quel momento ogni uomo della
terra aveva quasi 8mila metri quadrati
di foresta sono passati solo 25 anni 28
anni e oggi io ne ho 5.400 di meri
quadrati circa il 30 per cento in meno e
quando i miei figli che siedono lì
mi stanno guardando si laureeranno bene
loro ne avranno solo 4mila metri
quadrati il 50 per cento in meno da me
ai miei figli in una sola generazione
dimezziamo un rapporto tra foreste e
uomini
ora noi siamo una società civile
sviluppata facciamo queste cose dovremmo
razionalmente capire dove stiamo andando
e capire dove questo ci porterà ma
realmente lo sappiamo
intendo lo stiamo facendo con cognizione
di causa
sappiamo esattamente cosa fanno gli
alberi per noi oggi stiamo ancora
comportando come i co boy nella prateria
infinita del far west
pensando che le risorse del pianeta
siano semplicemente infinite che
possiamo prendere quello che vogliamo
nella realtà dovremmo cominciare a
ragionare come gli astronauti dentro una
capsula dove l'aria l'acqua il cibo
tutto è limitato tutto va gestito in
maniera responsabile per poter
continuare il viaggio
ritorniamo alle foreste sappiamo cosa
hanno fatto per noi e cosa stanno
facendo
beh se lo chiedete un bambino cosa ci
fanno le foreste la prima risposta è il
legno il legno certo potremmo definirlo
quasi l'eroe è nascosto della
civilizzazione ci ha sempre accompagnato
dai primi strumenti che abbiamo preso in
mano per diventare poi i cacciatori poi
agricoltori fino allo strumento principe
per costruire le nostre case era
rinnovabile cresceva da solo attorno a
noi legno poi dal legno e poi abbiamo
fatto il fuoco e con il fuoco ci siamo
impadroniti di una forma di energia
questo ci ha reso completamente diversi
da tutti gli altri animali sul pianeta
perché con l'energia e la potenza
dell'uomo è potuta crescere in maniera
enorme il fuoco tutt'oggi è importante
la bioenergia bruciare legno rappresenta
il 60 per cento dell'energia rinnovabile
d'europa più della somma di tutte le
altre energie rinnovabili ma legno poi
ci ha dotato di un altra cosa della
carta
la carta che è stata il supporto delle
idee dell'uomo supporto della cultura il
ponte della cultura da uno stato
all'altro da una persona all'altra da
una generazione all'altra senza la carta
io sono sicuro oggi non ci sarebbe tel
questi servizi del bosco sono servizi
materiali concreti fisici possiamo
toccare e le foreste però ci danno molto
altro tutta una serie di servizi che noi
definiamo immateriali ma che sono
importantissimi
facciamo fatica a descriverli però lì
capiamo le foreste regolano il ciclo
dell'acqua ad esempio il 70 per cento
dell'acqua che torna dalla terra verso
l'atmosfera per poi di precipitare come
pioggia bene 70 per cento passa
attraverso le foglie gli alberi poi
proteggono al suolo dall'erosione e il
suolo è il substrato sul quale possiamo
produrre cibo possiamo produrre tutto
quello che serve per la nostra vita
gli alberi su una base della bellezza
dei paesaggi sono la culla della
diversità
gran parte degli organismi viventi
vivono nelle foreste e proteggere le
foreste è l'unico modo che abbiamo per
poter conservare infine argomento di
questi giorni gli alberi cercano in
quanto possono di mitigare i cambiamenti
climatici circa il 30 per cento delle
nostre emissioni di gas serra vengono
riassorbite dagli alberi e trasformate
in legno quindi di alberi fanno tutto
questo e io mi chiedo ma se tutti noi
sappiamo il valore di queste cose legno
fuoco la carta il paesaggio l'aria
l'acqua elementi fondamentali della
nostra vita
com'è possibile che accettiamo di
ridurre di 50 per cento rapporto tra
foreste uomo in una sola generazione
bene io credo che il problema stia alla
base nel valore nel valore che noi diamo
a queste cose nel valore reale di
mercato rispetto al valore intrinseco
che han
ragioniamoci un attimo cos'è il valore
alla fine il valore è
nella nostra economia di mercato non è
altro che l'incontro si dice tra la
domanda e l'offerta tra quanti cercano
una cosa e quanti sono disposti a
venderla questo si produce un prezzo che
prodotto x una quantità ci dà un valore
quando in questo mercato e peperoni
costano 2 euro al chilo ne voglio due
chili mago 4 euro
semplice ora riusciamo a mettere gli
alberi e le foreste e le loro funzioni
in questa equazione è molto difficile
dov'è il mercato della diversità della
biodiversità ad esempio chi paga per
avere l'aria pulita
quanto è il valore del paesaggio
abbiamo dei problemi nell'inserire i
servizi ecosistemici immateriali servizi
che bosco ci dona e che non hanno
confini in uno schema che è quello che
guida le nostre logiche quando scegliamo
cosa fare di quello che sta attorno a
noi quando un contadino dell'amazzonia
deve decidere cosa fare della sua
foresta applica questa logica e non sa
dove inserire gli alberi e quindi
l'unica soluzione che trova a quello di
tagliarli e sostituirli con la canna da
zucchero con la soia con qualcosa che
invece sa vendere in quel mercato
io credo che oggi se vogliamo cambiare
questo percorso nella quale siamo
avviati no l'unica è trovare un modo di
inserire in questo schema logico anche
le funzioni che gli alberi hanno e che
non ci sono rappresentate dobbiamo
ritornare a dare un valore materiale
alle funzioni immateriali che le foreste
ci danno una soluzione c'è e
rappresentata ad oggi dai satelliti
sembra un passo molto grande e salire
nello spazio ma attorno a noi sopra le
nostre teste sono in orbita ormai decine
centinaia di satelliti che guardano il
pianeta in maniera continua e riescono a
dirci molto di cosa stanno facendo gli
alberi satelliti come quelli che
riprendono
ripreso queste immagini riescono di
fatto a vedere i singoli alberi di tutto
il pianeta
questo santa rita in mano a mano sta
focalizzando proprio su cui dove siamo
noi ci mostra il parco di villa erba
dove siamo
i suoi alberi quello centro convegni
quello di mezzo io ho un'immagine come
questa di tutto il pianeta ogni 5 giorni
e tramite questo riesco a vedere ad
esempio come sta cambiando la
riforestazione nel mondo quest'immagine
questa serie storica dal 1984 ci mostra
questa zona della bolivia ad esempio
dove foresta è stata progressivamente
sostituita dai campi queste immagini ci
permettono di capire come cambia il
clima di dove cambiano le foreste ci
permette di capire ci permettono di
capire come cambiano le nuvole quanto a
biomassa sta cambiando ci permettono
proprio di cominciare a quantificare
quei valori immateriali che fino ad oggi
non abbiamo mai messo sul mercato e
grazie a queste immagini stanno nascendo
dei meccanismi finalmente di mercato e
delle politiche come politica per il
contrasto la deforestazione delle
nazioni unite dove i paesi sviluppati
che hanno preso un grande vantaggio del
petrolio avvenimento ad esempio la
norvegia per l'europa stanno trasferendo
risorse economiche denaro ai paesi in
via di sviluppo che accettano di ridurre
il loro livello di deforestazione
i satelliti in questo gioco hanno un
ruolo fondamentale perché sono gli
strumenti che permettono all'intera
politica ambientale di prendere funzione
in maniera trasparente e accettabile da
tutte le parti
i satelliti ci stanno dando questa
visione dalla terra una visione
dall'alto quasi come la visione che da
bambini cercavamo quando salivamo sugli
alberi
in effetti guardare le cose un po così
da lontano le rimette nella giusta
prospettiva
quando guardo la terra da così e questo
proprio una fotografia preso da un
satellite che sta un milione e mezzo di
chilometri da noi e che guarda tutta la
terra continuamente ogni mezz'ora quando
guardiamo la terra da così lontano
e veramente vediamo che non è una
teoria sconfinata è realmente una
capsula spaziale nella quale viviamo
tutti insieme con un'atmosfera che molto
sottile e delicata con degli oceani
della terra
queste immagini ci fa vedere che non
esistono confini è un'unica capsula che
dobbiamo in qualche maniera a proteggere
tutti insieme non ci sono alternative
questa immagine ci fa anche capire il
valore che abbiamo
nell'osservare nel valutare
nell'apprezzare quello che abbiamo
attorno a noi valore della natura valore
degli alberi ritornare a ripensare al
valore di delle funzioni che la natura
ed i servizi che la natura ci offre
anche se questi non hanno attualmente un
prezzo io credo che solo ripensando a
questo solo ritornando la nostra vita ad
apprezzarlo riusciremo alla fine
costruire un ponte un ponte che collega
le due sponde un po di questo fiume che
la nostra vita
la sponda del passato dove abbiamo
ereditato gli alberi dai nostri genitori
e la sponda del futuro la sponda dove
daremo e questi alberi nelle mani dei
nostri figli
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]